MELINDA EPLER:
I'm Melinda Epler.
WAYNE SUTTON: I'm Wayne Sutton.
We're the founders
of Change Catalyst.
We empower inclusive and
sustainable innovation
globally.
MELINDA EPLER: Welcome
to this series sponsored
by Women Techmakers,
Google's initiative that
provides visibility,
community, and resources
for women in technology.
Together we're helping tech
hubs to develop more inclusive
cultures, programs, and spaces.
WAYNE SUTTON: To create
an inclusive tech hub,
the first step is to establish
a baseline so you can understand
the current state of
diversity and inclusion
of your group or organization.
This requires creating a
method for data collection,
deploying it, and
analyzing the results.
MELINDA EPLER: It's important
to measure both diversity
and inclusion.
Data around diversity includes
race, gender, ability,
veteran status, sexual
preference, and age.
Data around inclusion includes
retention, turnover, safety,
comfort, belonging,
support, and access.
WAYNE SUTTON: Once
you have this data,
you can begin to establish
some goals for creating change.
Continuously measuring the
changes in this data over time
allows you to know whether or
not your inclusion efforts are
working or not working.
From the top down to the bottom
up, everyone in your community
must play an active role and be
held accountable for inclusion.
MELINDA EPLER:
Make sure you have
a code of conduct or harassment
policy clearly stated
and easy to find.
You also need to make sure
you enforce this policy, which
will make people feel safe.
WAYNE SUTTON: Develop an
annual strategic inclusion plan
across the entire organization.
Set goals and outcomes
you hope to achieve.
And develop processes
together to achieve them.
MELINDA EPLER: Each team
and individual needs
to establish their own stretch
goals around inclusion.
WAYNE SUTTON: Consider tying
these goals to performance
reviews to hold each
person accountable.
MELINDA EPLER: Create an
inclusive advisory group
to continuously measure,
advocate for, and maintain
culture change around inclusion.
This is a good way
to enroll people
in your group or organization
that care about this work.
As a tech hub, measure
and publish your goals,
being transparent about what
is working and not working.
And tell your ongoing
story of change.
WAYNE SUTTON:
Measure what matters
so you can change what matters.
Join us as we go deeper
into leadership, culture,
external programs, and
physical spaces of tech
hubs in the next videos.
MELINDA EPLER: For
more information
about Women Techmakers,
Change Catalyst,
and additional resources,
see the links below.
And share this series
with your community.
Let's work together to
create inclusive tech hubs
around the world.